toby maguire might have learned to throw
a punch for his spider-man movies but
how did he learn the boogie what's the
story with maguire's supposed back
injury before filming spider-man 2. this
is toby mcguire's spider-man fitness
journey
toby mcguire went through a nearly
unbelievable amount of training to
portray spider-man but he didn't join
the production without any fighting and
fitness experience whatsoever after
production had wrapped mcguire spoke
with howard stern about how he became a
part of the first spider-man film
according to maguire director sam raimi
wanted him for the lead role from the
very beginning but the executives at
sony needed a little bit more persuading
before they would believe that he could
convincingly play the wall crawler even
after sending in an audition tape there
were some doubts about whether or not he
was athletic enough or if he would
believably be able to fight off new
york's bad guys like a flesh and blood
superhero they saw the tape and they
said well
we know he can act we want to see him do
an action scene amid those doubts from
executives sam raimi stepped in to help
maguire secure the role for the sake of
demonstrating his capabilities the two
of them filmed a short video that
featured maguire performing some general
fighting moves and taking out some
anonymous villains while wearing a blue
unitard maguire wanted to show not only
that he could handle some intense fight
scenes but also that his body was
convincingly muscular he wasn't too far
away from looking the part already so he
pulled the unitard down around his waist
to show off the muscles he already had
the tape did the trick and shortly after
sending it in maguire was finally
approved to join the project and start
his superhero training
toby maguire might have come into
spider-man with some fighting
capabilities and some muscle definition
but that didn't exclude him from the
task of going through a grueling amount
of training mcguire said that prior to
filming the first spider-man movie he
spent five months training six days a
week to get into shape every day mcguire
worked out for four hours lifting
weights and training his body to move
like someone with superhuman strength
and agility maguire explained in an
interview with cinema.com before the
movie's release for someone like me who
wasn't exactly a fitness freak it was a
chance of a lifetime to work with top
trainers in different disciplines to get
in great shape i'm going to try to stay
buff as long as i can but it takes a lot
of discipline and staying away from your
favorite junk food the amount of time
and effort required to maintain that
spider-man body would be too much for
anyone other than the most dedicated gym
rat but the actor was able to get there
for the short window of time he needed
to for the sake of the movie maguire can
hardly be blamed for later admitting
that he left his grueling training
regimen by the wayside when the film was
finally done you're not superman you
know
toby mcguire's primary trainer on these
spiderman movies was celebrity trainer
gregory jean-roche of holistic fitness
jean roche described his method as
focusing on both body and mind for the
stars that he trained so getting in
touch with yourself knowing your
limitations on how your body works
of course the training also ensured that
mcguire looked the part too of the
famous shirtless shot zhuzhan roche said
i call it the champagne shot that was
day one of shooting we did all that and
we were like oh yeah
in a behind-the-scenes clip scott rogers
the co-stunt coordinator on spider-man 2
talked about the difficulties of
developing spider-man's fighting style
he wanted to rely on real fighting
techniques without making spider-man
look like a kung fu or gymnastics expert
the fights really had to have
spider-man's signature on them however
because toby maguire wanted to be able
to perform as much of spider-man's
fighting as possible he needed to
familiarize himself with all of the
techniques that were combined to create
the spider-man style luckily he had the
help of martial arts expert stephen ho
who previously played donatello and
teenage mutant ninja turtles 2 the
secret of the ooze the former ninja
turtle had high praise for mcguire's
work ethic when it came to his fight
training he was into it as an art form
as opposed to justino learning the
tricks he had to learn to look good on
camera
bulking up to play spider-man meant
lifestyle changes for toby maguire that
went well beyond simply spending several
hours a day in the gym he needed to
completely transform his diet to ensure
that he was eating enough calories and
getting enough protein to transform his
body mcguire told howard stern that
while preparing for the role he had a
nutritionist who helped him plan every
single one of his meals he would
sometimes eat five times a day just to
make sure he was getting enough energy
for his workouts to be effective the
superhero diet was even more of a
challenge for maguire than for other
actors because he couldn't rely on
eating traditional protein sources like
chicken and red meat mcguire became a
vegetarian in the mid-90s and he's never
looked back to keep himself sane during
the training process on each of the
films mcguire allowed himself to break
away from the intense diet and workout
restrictions on a regular basis the
regularly scheduled free days gave
maguire the reprieve he needed to keep
his enthusiasm going for months on end
sam raimi's first spider-man was such a
blockbuster success that sony wanted to
get a start on the sequel as quickly as
possible that arrangement worked well
for everyone but it had special benefits
for toby maguire the star wasn't shy
about admitting that he let his
superhero training regimen lapse after
filming the first movie when it came
time for mcguire to start hitting the
gym for spider-man 2 he found that he
hadn't entirely lost his touch and was
able to tone down his workout plan from
the original film he worked out anywhere
between two and four hours while
training for the sequel which was at
least an hour less each day compared to
his previous schedule training for the
sequel was less about getting ripped and
more about getting back on his feet
leading up to the production of
spider-man 2 rumors spread that toby
maguire could potentially be replaced by
jake gyllenhaal because of a serious
problem with his back my back
open my back
after completing the film maguire
clarified what had happened in an
interview with superhero hype mcguire
said his lower back condition had been
affecting him for several years through
spider-man all the way until right now
but he could never be certain what would
cause the pain to flare up maguire was
intimidated by the amount of ambitious
stunts planned for spider-man 2 and he
felt that it was his responsibility to
disclose his condition to everyone
working on the film maguire spent two
weeks taking it easy on his back and
worrying about whether or not he'd be
able to take part in the film during
that time his back started to get better
just as rumors of his replacement
started to spread mcguire started to
work carefully with the film's stunt
coordinators and by the time filming
began he was shocked by how good he felt
he told superhero hype in actuality the
stunts were easier for me and my back
was fine the whole way through i don't
know what made them better i was more
comfortable in them doing the certain
stunts and the aerial stuff was easier
i thought you were sick
i got better
once toby mcguire had settled his
concerns about his lower back condition
he wanted to take on as many of the
stunts in spider-man 2 as possible he
viewed it as his responsibility to be
the man behind the mask on screen as
much as possible he told superhero hype
there are certain things i have to do
and want to do because you're bringing
life into a character he also admitted
to taking a certain amount of pride in
being able to truly see himself as
spider-man in the film saying quote i
like to point stuff in there so you
could feel me in there maguire's
commitment to the role clearly impressed
his co-workers particularly director sam
raimi who occasionally had to hold
maguire back and let a stunt double take
over in a scene sam raimi said in a
behind-the-scenes featurette toby did a
tremendous amount of his own stunts in
this picture as much as
i would allow him to do he wanted to do
everything
for spider-man and spider-man 2 toby
maguire had to completely transform his
body he lifted weights tirelessly worked
on cardiovascular exercises and mastered
a wide variety of fighting techniques
but years of training still left maguire
unprepared for the most memorable moment
in the trilogy's conclusion the dance
scene the actor told blackfilm.com all
about the new training he underwent for
the trilogy's final film i worked with
some people a choreographer and a couple
of dance people he had to learn the
right moves to bring peter parker's
symbiote-inspired overconfidence to life
and fans will likely never let him
forget it maguire explained that the
basic idea of it was choreographed and
then we kind of riffed on that and had
fun from there their fun riffing became
the most infamous scene in just about
any superhero movie maguire may have
approached the dance training with the
same enthusiasm as his fitness training
but audiences haven't yet appreciated it
on the same level
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]